this could be lore this could be myth
yeah but somewhere I read
that when you were doing your contract
for data for the movies yeah what you
did four movies right
that you put in the contract that I'll
do this but you have to put me in
another movie ever each time is that
true well the first movie uh uh I I felt
I had some leverage because uh which
actors rarely has yeah so when you have
I mean particularly actors of my stature
rarely have you know me too you know uh
but uh I I they had a contract they had
it all worked out and I didn't really
want to I knew we had to start shooting
immediately because the script was
already written we finished the series
and two weeks later started the the
movie and so the negotiations got really
intense and really fast yeah and and
basically I said look I'm not doing it
uh unless you know I make x amount of
money and more importantly I get another
role only did that once uh that there
has to be something that's not Star Trek
uh that Paramount Pictures is doing
right now and uh so they they you know
it's a long story but it turned out I I
copped that deal I was the first you
know first maybe an only deal I ever got
that I wanted but
um
but there was a clause in it that if
they didn't find another movie for me to
do uh they had to pay me off you know
some nice figure and as it turned out
they they did not find another movie for
me to do or want to find another movie
for me to do so they just paid me
see I thought the movie was maybe
Independence Day no but in fact before
that all came to a finish I had already
gotten Independence Day so I didn't
really care whether they found me
another movie at that point I thought
well then just pay me and that's fine
was that probably your biggest payday
that first one no and I guess not
because the ones you did sequentially
those became paydays right they're gonna
give you a raise on each one yeah
exactly wow yeah that's so cool that you
have a series and you think okay I'm on
a TV series and back then if you were on
TV it didn't you didn't cross over to
film now it's like that you could do
whatever you want you could do you could
be a YouTuber reality star be a movie
star all at the same time right I don't
have to give you I called a movie star
but whatever yeah but um
the fact that Star Trek
they wanted the movie version with the
TV cast is probably blew you guys away
well there'd already been a precedent
for it with the original cast oh I guess
that's true that's true so you always
saw I guess you always thought that well
we thought once we were quote unquote
successful that maybe there were movies
in our future and and indeed there were